hey how's it going bros my name is Pippa
welcome back to life is strange we're
gonna pull an episode for today I'm
really excited I'm a little late on it
because yesterday I was working really
hard on another video I'm a busy man
walking it no one gives a [ __ ] all right
I heard since I am a lid on it I heard a
lot of like great things about this
episode in particular it's called
episode 4 dark room I'm very excited I'm
very very excited so excited that I'm
wearing female female outfit and you
know what
boys gonna wear Kawai outfits - why are
you know if I want to look fabulous and
that can do it if I want to I love the
background music or the soundtrack of
this game
it's so nice previously on life is
strange whoa I completely forgot where
we left off oh and the the voice actor
for that girl max let's talk about your
super she tweeted that she watched my
video which is awesome I know this isn't
pleasant for any of us miss Caulfield
please tell us everything
hey stem and Louise that's Rachel's
bracelet why the [ __ ] are you wearing
her bracelet calm yourself
alright it was a gift max we have to
find Rachel soon like you said it's time
to start the search for clues welcome to
my domain let's
find what we want and beat it max you
better come check out these files Rachel
in the darkroom over and over that's it
listen I found pictures of Rachel and
Frank being more than friend I can't
believe she was banging Frank
Rachel straight-up lied to my face why
didn't she say anything so who do you
most want to blame my [ __ ] dad of
course hello
oh yeah now I remember how it ended
Jesus Christ do you know what it's like
to wait for your father to come home
with her kid ever since he died my life
has been dipped in [ __ ] Chloe I am
awesome we are awesome how did she get
it oh my god hello are you even
listening Maxine this is totally [ __ ]
up what really changed max Caulfield
hold on Chloe you have a visitor
it's that blood fly effect oh my god
okay I don't know why they didn't show
but she was in a wheelchair the blue
haired girl if you watch the last
episode you would know you obviously
watched oh by the way since I'm late on
this did you wait for me you didn't
sneak off to someone else did you huh
did you you watch someone else's this
really you know that hurts
well do they beatbox randomly or dude do
they do they make awkward sex jokes
probably night do they talk over to
dialogue probably not
so I hope you enjoyed yourself hope
you're happy beautiful gorgeous I feel
pressure now that someone who's like
made the game or as part of the game
watch my videos puts a lot of pressure
on me alright
you can't just do that I don't wanna
know about it it's cool though I'm just
kidding it's awesome
hello how are you people of life is
strange I love your game it's it's it's
fun and then cool see you see how
awkward it just became Jesus Christ can
the game please start already we're the
dead Wales anyway any Wales I was almost
a joke think okay well it it seems like
we're gonna explore the dark room today
excited
I can tell by your face you're so
excited Jesus sit down oh my god
that is awkward no that's horrible can
she talk
it's weird hanging out with you again
Oshie I'm glad we are though it was nice
that you sent me actual letters it's
more than any of my other friends to
them
and you even wrote on that cool
parchment paper so max so pretentious
but I love writing on it like in English
poet you deserve the best stationery
what is probably easier to write and to
visit me oh snap anyway not totally you
probably wanted to avoid awkward
conversations like this uh pretty much
yeah Wow saddest thing you can do is
treat me like a baby I still want to
laugh and talk [ __ ] with my best friend
oh can we stop this is seriously the
best view of the sunset
what if photographers call that the
golden hour see without you here and
have no clue but you could take some
amazing shots Senate whales whales are
so sad every just not know how do you
feel
gonna talk about the whales at least I'm
alive here with you no one cares that
there's four washed-up whales in the
beach there's literally no one there
real survivor Chloe I know you have to
deal with so much I don't want anybody
else feeling sorry for me I can do that
along with my parents my dad still feels
guilty about my imminent car so so
that's how it happened okay I want to
hear about the accident tell me about
the actually talk about the accident we
never actually have huh there's not much
to say some prick in an SUV cut me off
and I flew into a ditch do you remember
everything I saw everything in bullet
time I felt my back snap and
and that was the last thing I ever felt
in my body when I woke up in the
hospital I literally couldn't move a
muscle
that's gotta be scary I I don't know
what to say don't say anything I'm just
happy I did get to see you again they
could have ended up vanishing out of the
blue like that girl from Blackwell so
she doesn't even know Rachael then you
mean Rachel amber when was the last time
you talked to her uh never I just read
about her in the news I didn't even know
her name you did this is such a
different world than when we were kids
isn't it
afterthat snow and eclipse it's more
like the end of the world it might be it
might be but I like to think we can
still change things for the better I'd
like to think that too but I don't have
much hope these days I know things seem
out of control but as long as we're
together I don't feel afraid hanging out
with you makes me feel like a total kid
again you don't even know listen Chloe
I'm sorry I haven't been out to see you
more that was wrong you're my best
friend
max
thanks for coming out to see me you're
doing awesome I don't um my nose is
getting cold maybe we should get back to
my place
it is hella cold out here hello oh it's
so sad
it's is it liking a little bit I can't
really tell sometimes it's so say it
okay can they at least poke the whales
give him a little slap on the booty like
how can you force me so much the whales
are just whaling there that was almost a
joke I think great great start bet
you're glad you're waited now in here
here straight up comedy like that look
at that [ __ ] alright this is max house
no it's not it's her house great it's a
pretty high-tech lair feels like a
hi-tech cell but I am lucky my parents
bus there has to take care of me I know
it's hard for them mm-hmm they're
grateful you are here with them right
especially when they can't even take a
walk alone sometimes I act like a total
teenage brat just to give them an excuse
to yell at me pathetic oh I know Chloe
you're a great daughter yes you're kind
and sensitive when you don't even have
to be trust me I still get my rage on
especially when a nurse has to watch
while I take a dump or she can wipe my
bum her when doctors flip me around like
I was a science doll I can't even
imagine but you're still amazing you
always have been since we were kids
thanks again for coming max I need to
get my drink on uh can you can you bring
me some water
oh my god oh my god okay so why don't we
go back like she doesn't seem better off
this way the snow Doh I guess not
everything changed man I'm such an
[ __ ] she like asked for water and I'm
just like the snow Doh I think this is
empty
what did she get like oh man
no wonder my throat is dry I don't think
I've talked this much the whole year
have you ever thought about doing a
podcast or something I wish I could
punch your face right now the podcast
dude I am a pod in a cast boring it was
just a thought I know you're just trying
to help
yeah that's become a bad habit of mine
you sound like an adult now seems like
we were kids in another life
you're right you're right I wish I could
take us all the way back there again
wish I could build us a DeLorean oh well
um with your scientific mind you might
do that but time travel can screw things
up too
Plus he'd have to be my living assistant
to help me build a machine as you can
see I can't keep all my other friends
away I have a quick question can she
return to the point where she lost every
words in the car accident like I don't
how does it work I forgot how her power
works anyway I'm sure there's a reason
behind it you have me you have me I'm
not leaving accept all the years I mean
I loved your cards and photos but I know
I wasn't around much no excuses I'm a
loser but I am trying to make things
right
oh dude you're not super max and I'm not
trying to guilt trip you that's what my
parents are for
they love you they love you so much I
know my mom and dad are so cute
I always pop in here and make sure
everything's okay with me I think Joyce
and William are incredible
max the accident has been so hard on
that our insurance sucks
and the medical bills are [ __ ] insane
can you pay all the bills no way they
keep the numbers away from me but it
doesn't take much research to find out
I'm costing my parents almost a million
dollars a year
Chloe you're priceless
no pun intended you're such a geek
that's why I love you
of course I know a geek when I be one
see I'm practically a human
entertainment system it would be sweet
to chill out together and watch a movie
like when you'd spend the night at my
house what do you want to watch uh I
think I'm in like a mellow Bladerunner
mood I always cry at the end plus you
know I always wanted to have cool
colored bangs like Chris I know I look
incredible oh let's get this show on the
road and you better not fall asleep on
me like you always do when we watch
movies
I remember max swear I won't fall asleep
not when your hair is so sad okay I'm a
man what's up
I'm not crying [ __ ] you oh my god I mean
that makes for her member 12 can the
music chill Jesus Christ where's the
movies
this has to be it ah here's the DVD aha
a tweet hipster no no no no what
happened
I want the DVD give me the DVD put in
there we go I swear that's what I cling
I'm gonna cost a million dollar a year
that's crazy
sweet and free health care we're gonna
watch the whole film okay I ship them so
much Jesus Christ can we go back in time
so they can make out mm-hmm what what
just happened did we did we fall asleep
oh my god they both fell asleep that's
adorable
okay a little creepy but cute
I cannot believe you fell asleep so fast
how dare you I know you were beat down
after the day with me and Blade Runner
is a pretty dreamy movie to watch at
night do you think that good is
replicant sorry I can see you're not
wide awake like me no I'm sorry I
crashed so hard it must be so
uncomfortable is like okay I do have a
mother and father when you're not
falling asleep on me you are a [ __ ] in
the morning the company I keep
Wow yesterday was such a blast and we
watched you dead well it's great seeing
you and Blade Runner
I think things were different we were
just dorky kids but being with you made
me feel like when we were a little
pirates jumping and running through the
forests again
it meant a lot to me just to chill out
with you and [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm getting
my regular head pains can you please go
upstairs and get my my morphine injector
in the bathroom morphine injector it's
it's total Star Trek [ __ ] you can't even
see the needle seriously I need it my
parents keep the swag upstairs because
they think I can't get to it but you can
max like a pirate right I'm on it Chloe
oh my god
so depressing okay let's get her her
drugs bad bit about that Bell skippity
back Babu I love me I love you I don't
think you should be here you're supposed
to know God what was that sound we tried
so hard to save his life and look what
happened what do you do with such as ie
Lima we're going upstairs apparently
just skipping him completely okay he's
just like eating cereal so intensely
that he does not even recognize this oh
this is so sad oh let's look at this a
blue butterfly I'm sure this is a total
coin set no max it's not a coincidence
you got it all wrong hey I'm taller than
air Hey
all right where's the morphine a letter
what do we got I ever heard much about
Williams brother oh my god I made a mess
hi Bill
it started for not staying in touch
since the accident work hasn't been
piling up and that's been piling up and
I'm being sent to Salt Lake City is that
an acre and E it's bothering me
to oversee a new parking lot you have to
go where the work is these days I wish I
could have sent you a bigger check but
you know the story money is nobody's
favorite thing maybe I'll see you next
spring for a visit kiss Chloe and Joyce
for me hang in there
your brother Aaron okay
shoes Chloe always did love stomping
around in her boots okay well now you're
just wasting my time max shoes
commenting on shoes max is that what
we're doing at her we're obviously
looking for morphine Jesus Christ where
did she say it was again I completely
forgot this looks scary I don't like
this room can I turn on the lights
this must be the morphine song just more
medicine just more medicine where's that
must be in here here it is I never
thought I'd be delivering morphine to my
best friend I mean to be fair you you
only wrote her letters every once in a
while I don't know if that counts this
best friend they changed the stairs to
oh gosh darn it no they don't and they
can never mind you talking about the
bells for himself that's a bit too
convenient isn't it and with him I saved
your life I saved your life William what
are you doing looking at bananas how
come any fruits you have how did you pay
for those fruits huh how Tammy William
am i bothering no man his sleigh yes max
I love going through Bill's kidding how
can you bother me I haven't seen you in
forever
I know you look exactly the same
it's so cool yes really ugly eyebrows
sorry I just really needed to say that
good for I'd be as scared if I didn't
look like me of course you seem more
adult now so what's on your mind why do
people keep saying that Cameron I was
impressed by Chloe's room and all the
high-tech equipment you should be we
could buy a few mansions for what it all
costs insurance helps but I don't know
max I know it must be hard on you guys
financially his bills are more like
crushing we have to mortgage our home
and that's pretty scary but but we'll
get through it
price is always right get it no I'm just
gonna go I have to go see if Chloe needs
anything it was so great talking with
you again
really what you act like it's the last
time I'm please keep me from these bills
whenever you want oh yeah I know he was
technically dead that's why I'm like
that okay my bad
that was a little heartless wasn't it
okay I like that painting what is it
she's like in pain I'm so sorry Jesus
Christ here you go I'm sorry I'm nosy
but not precise go ahead and plug it
right in it's so easy and painless um
okay but get ready to yell for your
folks if I screw up Oh trust me I will
did I do it right of course my pain just
keeps getting worse but you caught me on
a good day max I'm so grateful that I'm
even able to hang out with you see I'm
getting mushy you're so adorable do you
want anything else stop me if I'm being
too emo but can you grab one of the
photo albums over there I'd like to
check out some old pictures of us and we
were kids please my tire is like emo
ground zero plus max Caulfield does not
pass up a photo op with Chloe price ever
okay well she's really many then [ __ ]
alright alright alright I'm gonna take
this and then I'm gonna show it to her
look at this picture really have to pee
it's really annoying me
you barely just got started I don't take
break now Jesus Christ we're looking at
pictures what is that thing around her
neck it's like a dead snake okay
probably is oh my god
look how little we are there we look
like toys I remember that day by the
lighthouse my dad was pissed at us he
actually tried to give us a timeout and
you laughed at him my dad would have
banished me vanished let's turn the page
again I don't I don't [ __ ] know Jesus
Christ I ride all right
husband picture looks so badass in her
pirate gear we should have taken over
Arcadia babe when we had the chance
there's still time for you
she said it oh man there we are making
pancakes I love that shot of us that's
hard to believe my dad took that picture
only five years ago man I really want
pancakes I really see was like yesterday
larly I wish it was me too
that's how we do it that's how it's done
that's how we go back in time with
pictures it all makes sense
my respiratory system is failing and and
it's only getting worse I've heard the
doctors talking about it when they
thought I was knocked out oh so I know
I'm just putting off the inevitable
while my parents suffer along and I will
too
oh my god this isn't how I want things
to him oh I'm saying she's talking about
you again has been so special I just
wanted to feel like when we were kids
running around Arcadia Bay and
everything was possible and you made me
feel that way today I want this time
with you to be my last memory do you
understand
oh yes I do all you have to do is crank
up the IV to 11
ah no that's - I can't you know what
cooee
I'll just drift asleep dreaming of us
here together forever
thank you so much I'm so proud of you
for following your dreams don't forget
about me never I love your max see you
around
sooner than you think
alright I'm gonna give that break oh man
oh man I did not cry did not that was
not sorry me I never ever shed it we're
gonna go back again huh why can't you go
back to the day of the in event do we
have to be there maybe that's probably
it
what do we my supposed oh yeah I have to
focus image I remember it's harder than
it looks
[Music]
isn't that it oh I got it my controller
is vibrating some day dad will get one
of them newfangled computers
I hope the flash didn't scare you max
this is a keeper uh can I just pause can
we what's it called in English you
Nastasia this happens call East Asia
Anastasia when you Anastasia when you
you let someone kind of die because
they're in so much pain and it's just
what they want I know that's illegal
maybe in some countries is it I don't
know much about it I think it's an
interesting topic at least and it's I
don't know I guess I just wanted to
bring it up that's why I killed it
because I feel like that's the right
thing to do I think when when lost
getting bold in these things it just
hurts families and the ones they love
and I think it's their own decision if
they want to go then I think they should
be let go I guess that's why I picked it
just wanted to say that okay great
hello hey honey what oh I didn't know
you had to get groceries of course I'll
come pick you up
haha you can't hide from me forever and
no clear from you say skims fantastic
night your mother promised to make us a
world-famous salmon surprise with
chocolate cake for dessert max he'll be
here too right that makes all
max you were being so [ __ ] strange
like you're never gonna see us again
Chloe I'm so sorry I tried to make
things different for you I I did try
I'm sorry I don't know exactly what
you're talking about but come on you'll
have made things different like my whole
life you're my best friend I'm the field
trained you know the [ __ ] out would be
sorry for
Gee's friends forever oh my god and when
we grow up we're taking over the world
Dawson whatever happens I want you to be
strong even if you feel like I wasn't
there for you because I will never
abandon you Chloe I'll always have your
back always
oh my god Jesus Christ
stop please huh okay all right
we're through we did it we did it we I'm
proud of you okay it's over no more
feelings no more number of that [ __ ]
all right now we can play video games
that's obviously about
what okay I get it
wait we get it it's we're reverting what
we did
that's not happy yep that's not having
that chaired thing no weird we almost
got killed by that [ __ ] instead I
lock her in blue though she looks way
prettier just it's interesting how color
can make difference
I want you remember when I had blue hair
it was weird
[ __ ] up the green screen otherwise I'd
probably go back to blue hair honestly
this is too annoying to edit and your
hair is just [ __ ] gone what video
games
dolphins look at that dolphin dolphins
are smart mammals I would make out with
the dolphin if it wasn't unethical sorry
I just wanted my opinion on that topic
as well just think it's damn right
insane how society cleavage in the
background Jesus you sound high but
thanks for the morning group since we
were up all night playing CSI Arcadia
Bay I was still spaced out here trying
to put all this info together nice -
hello music 101 I hope you weren't
messing around with time while sleeping
not anymore
I'm just spaced out - welcome back to
the real world
I don't think I can ever tell Chloe
about what happened no that's probably
not a good idea hey by the way I had
weddings in the future and I killed you
great I also made out with a dolphin
as all the documents we stole
copyright this video please this is what
the music does hello i'm just talking
over Lily right now so it won't get come
alright great times Dolphins are great I
I liked their butts i they have great
butts
I don't understand do the habits I don't
know maybe they do maybe they don't
will we ever truly find out will this
song ever [ __ ] in that's all these
things that I don't know but I'm gonna
keep talking look at that [ __ ] [ __ ]
look that [ __ ] [ __ ] there's [ __ ]
[ __ ] everywhere I'm sorry if this is
knowing I just have to do it
it's not my fault is 2-games fault why
would you put copyrighted music in Jesus
cries I'm ruining this wonderful moment
in this video it's all about the
atmosphere isn't it
I'm totally killing it I'm so sorry you
should just play the game yourself
instead and you won't have to have this
[ __ ] okay great
I'm glad we settled this what is she
doing she's just pretending to be it oh
my god I had a voice crack that's
awesome
okay well this is the longest song ever
it's a wonderful song though isn't it
love this soundtrack I want to download
the soundtrack
am I supposed to click something look at
the holy [ __ ] I could have just call a
puzzle so far are you kidding me
oh my god what are you back there the
door rang
I got new shoes
[Music]
I like how I I forgot I was wearing this
okay we were looking for puzzles said it
what's my objective Clos and I decided
to get out of there and catch up and
what am I missing
I'm missing something out RNA this
butterfly photo seems like a million
years ago how much time if I altered
sense that snow always makes me think of
William and Chloe what am i doing I
don't I missed her sentence [ __ ] yes so
close yet so far away we have to do
three main things right
what things yeah please tell me one
decipher Frank's logbook uh-huh to get
Nathan's phone to find out where he's
been during the vortex Club parties with
Kate and Rachel okay and see whatever
hidden shed he's gotten his messages I
agree with that beatstep douche dad
until he tells us about Frank Nathan and
the darkroom too bad I don't have a gun
anymore yes that's the solution we'll
have to do this on our own dude at least
let me kick his ass then rewind fine
whatevs their power which I can't waste
on [ __ ] like that
well Blackwell would be in big trouble
at least you let me take that money to
pay for ink off don't remind me I just
want him off your back Frank our back I
know you should get busy in the garage
to see what dirt you can dig up I'm
gonna cyberstalk some names and see
where that leads words a who and be
careful of step crack unless you want to
hang out with him after you stood up for
his ass yesterday no please
all right Iran can't abuse this level of
my rewind power it's way too dangerous
and I need to navigate oh my god I don't
mean to interrupt her sentence I'm sorry
max EMU can I call you max EMU
Maximo I got new shoes maxi move got new
shoes maxi moo boo-boo
max and move maximum maximum max moo
maxi maxi oh yeah for those who don't
know this is that one guy that we're
totally friends owning it feels weird to
be on this side of the friends owning an
area it's usually on the opposite end
Chloe actually taxi I'm sure I sure
didn't have her number at least I still
get to go ape with you unless you went
to chill with Chloe or we could all go
one panting gasps is it a cool I have to
jet talk to you later
he's just right now be like I want to
talk to you now máximo I love you I love
you oh oh oh that's what he's literally
doing it probably rubbing one out to
Maxie me oh my god what just happened
okay let's go in here talk to this guy
great I need a filter fell to myself so
sorry maybe there's some new clues
around maybe there's some new clues
around while he's right there seems like
a bad idea mr. Hyde help me out here
thing I can do for you max shave your
mustache it looks stupid I was just
waiting for Chloe to get out of the
bathroom so we can go I owe you one
so I'll pretend what you just said is
true
Missy excuse me that's miss Caulfield
sir you and Chloe still better be
careful where you wander that'll be yes
ma'am
there
the dark places narky thank you very
much what do you mean by dark places I
can't tell you everything that's going
on it black what's with eyebrows in this
game okay
I'm sorry that's all I wanted to say
you've seen too much already so please
stay out of this max too late I already
know way too much so do you and Nathan
Prescott
that little [ __ ] asked Nathan Prescott
is lucky he only got suspended
I don't think luck had anything to do
with it I could have been suspended too
I didn't have all the evidence at the
time I am she's wearing those pens way
too high sorry max anyway I think we can
both agree it's been a hard week on all
of us especially poor Kate Marsh oh
she's dead so it's not a bad week it's a
bad life all right you did it I try to
help Kate I tried to help Kate you tried
to help her more than anybody max I sure
dan you [ __ ] her up then once I left
that goddamn dorm roof wide open I knew
Caitlin
you even made it to the roof before me
or anybody I knew Kate was desperate too
so did mr. Jefferson that guy is an
elitist prick I'm off duty so I can save
it
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha when Chloe calls me step
douche these artists live in a fantasy
world why do you say that these aren't
farts are all about themselves when I
was in the service I hated the
photographer's and try to pose me in
their anti-war [ __ ] well Blackwell
Academy is a school for artists so yeah
this isn't the best place for you I have
a family here max
and I think Blackwell is the best place
for me since the only I know what's
happening that's why I'm working out the
new Blackwell surveillance plan to
protect future students so they don't
end up like Rachel amber and Kate Marsh
although you're like a walking
surveillance system
I appreciate you standing up for me but
I have to be a hard-ass and tell you and
Chloe to stay the hell out of this
things are just gonna get more ugly
Chloe night
can take care of ourselves such an
awkward conversations me max I have to
get back to my camera see I'm an artist
too oh excuse me I have to get back to
my camera I'm an artist I do appreciate
you standing up Walker
hey David what you hiding yeah what's
your hot and David what's your hiding
girl David what you're hiding
[Music]
does that mean we have to find what is
this what is this I see a painting with
people on it who are these people
is that a cat dancing on drugs
that's art people don't appreciate it
let's look at the television whose poor
wheels are like beached angels what is
going on here really really fat angels I
would say Joyce really wants David and
Chloe to be a family I accept your offer
of dinner in a movie maybe Chloe would
like to come along I'll call you later
xxx oh oh diet choices [ __ ] so kawaii I
don't even know how to make this all
started with my vision of a tornado
while Arcadia Bay was until now
considered a quaint fishing and tourist
nuke on the Oregon coast the town that
the time for goddess since the beginning
of this week and the little eye of the
environmental storm starting with the
freak snowfall and unprecedented eclipse
really fancy words here hey I'm nailing
it I'm proud of myself dying birds and
now half a dozen beach wales Arcadia Bay
strange weather is being studied by
prominent state and national scientists
apparently including
and it's a what what's even more
incredible than these echo phenomena is
the fact that I said phenomena whatever
that not a single metrologist has
offered any actual theory on even or
even reason for this atmospheric havoc
continued on the next page you'd think
that people would actually give some
theories that's kind of strange but I
guess is that strange because life is
strange
sorry you know what I need to stop
someone stop me please
plus place I need a stat man all right
Oh beautiful music okay we did something
oh there it is that's what we needed it
seen you snag his keys enter the ninja
now that's so weird because I'm totally
standing next to it I didn't do anything
don't talk to myself in third-person
that's weird oh god no no no no not
again why do I keep I double-clicked god
damnit man what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you mate guys let's put it back alright
okay all right we got this Bruce I know
it's a lot frustrating with me playing
sometimes I can't but just know that I
loved you anyway and it's nothing
personal nothing personal well well
alright so now we went to the fuse box
and we can go around
excelencia as i'd like to say all right
let's take it take a ticket gotcha
better him it doesn't matter if he sees
you because you can just work better if
David doesn't actually see ya but we
have the key right oh my god look at
that face you look like my next mistake
loves a game wanna play
a
no no new money suit and tie I can read
you like a magazine ain't it funny
rumors laugh and I know I can
technically sing songs that we'll get
back to protect oh my god don't time
stop referring yourself like that you're
better than that I wonder where he
thought the keys went
I am the keymaster please don't say
things like that max I thought we talked
about this
car eating yes coordinates well oh you
took a picture of that really that fight
you remember it has a nice tank top I
registration that's me what does it say
pay up are we just gonna okay all right
you know max is such a cute character
jeepers remember when we played Last of
Us and I I said that I was the girl's
name and remember I said that she was
cute I never say well you're a perfect
she's on the rapes can I just appreciate
two things Jesus Christ am I talking
over the dialogue I'm so sorry now let's
go find out what nathan is hiding in his
room we have to be that was really fast
talking now it's time for Nathan
Prescott to be afraid of us yeah we
should we should pull a gun on him am i
right ladies
up top
yes I felt good we about this SATA web l
all right brothers hope you enjoyed this
episode if you did go ahead and leave it
like it supports the show the series or
whatever the you want to call it
thank you for us for watching I had a
lot of fun playing and I will see you in
the next one where we'll finish this
episode for all right cool as always
thing was watching I said it twice stay
off
[Music]